today curator Katie Barrett shares how
one of the most famous British artists
of all time
took her sketchbook into surgery in
another story from the stories why would
a famous artist be sat in an operating
theatre sketching Barbara Hepworth
daughter was very ill in the 1940s she
had a bone infection disease and was
sent to a surgeon called Norman kapner a
Norman Kepner invited Barbara hope was
to go and draw in surgery because he
felt she must have an affinity with
looking at human body and this sketch
book comes from a series of operations
that she saw at the London clinics that
were to do in an operation called
fenestration of the ear and absolutely
we can this is amazing because it's the
only surviving sketchbook from all of
the observations that did some of them
are very simple you can just see the
head of the surgeon here he's looking
through the equipment then you get on to
other kinds of annotation so she's
marking the equipment that's being used
later on she marks colors so she's doing
these incredibly quickly obviously she's
not allowed to change what's happening
in the surgery she can't make them stop
when they're in a nice calm position so
she's recording what she thinks she
might want to draw later what makes it
stand out as one of her pieces okay so
it's interesting actually this this
period of work is very unusual in
Barbara Hepworth work as a whole because
she didn't tend to do bigger studies she
tended to be very abstract but she wrote
quite a lot about these observations
that she made in the surgery this is
actually the sketch which became the
work in the tate and we can see how
she's got this real interest in hands
you can and faces you can see the hands
and faces and the tools and she was
particularly interested in what she
called the kind of harmony and beauty of
how surgery worked together and she saw
it as naturally making the kind of
composition that she was trying to make
in her sculpture and also the process of
doing an operation where this the
fenestration actually involves hammering
a bit of bone out of the skull uses a
hammer and chisel which are the kind of
tools she of course was using in
sculpture so she was particularly
interested in those kind of parities
between surgery and art